you know the other day we were talking
about this gym okay that they reopened
in defiance of the governor's order
yesterday yes yeah right and I didn't
believe that you were gonna go I went
and he did it's it's it's like three
miles away and and it you called it or
actually I said it's gonna be nothing
and yeah I've been there closed yeah of
course of course right like I can't
imagine that it says online that they're
open to like 11 or whatever you got but
so this is a story that actually came
out the other day Alan Dershowitz says
power to plunge a needle into your arm
you know Dershowitz says forced
vaccinations are constitutional what
yeah I'm sorry excuse me doesn't the
Constitution say something like if the
government isn't granted the power
specifically it can't do it or something
and amendment as a tenth one
well that technically leaves it to
that's the date enumeration of the right
states or whatever anything that's not
specifically given to the federal
government is left to the states
hmm so my first question for all of you
you can comment as we get started if the
government vaccine man knocked on your
door and said you know drop trou turn
around the injections are coming what
would you do would you do forced
vaccinations nope this is creepy man
and and they said 18 months for like a
safe vaccination and now they're like
claiming they're gonna have one by the
end of the year and it's like that's
like in a nine month period you're gonna
rock out a vaccination and then forced
it upon everybody so do you think we'll
end up with like you know what the
middle ID was no it was a medication and
the I think was in the 80s okay and
pregnant women who took it their babies
were born without limbs so they'd like
just something like that like it just
like arms mess people on their shoulders
yeah that was yes the middle light I
think it was gold all right do you think
we'll end up with something like that
yeah from a rushed back seat do you
think we'll end up with like more lux
and like you know people who can't like
you know basically they get injected in
like all sudden if they're forced
underground or like you think you'll be
like zombies or it just renders and
anyone who has it like sterile or so
like I'm kidding I'm going really
extreme but you know you know we're
worth the Georgia Guidestones like what
was it five hundred million people in
the Mack
but it's people that believe that you
know for sure Bill Gates is isn't he
saying that we're was too many of us and
he's the one like all about vaccines and
yes I mean I'm really diving way out
there I'll just know that I mean I don't
know you know we are we are now at the
point where I I mean I like to say we're
on the precipice of some kind of
Boogaloo but I agree let me tell you
while listening something the other day
no no hold on for the past week or two
weeks I personally have been talking
about on my channels the lockdowns the
constitutionality of it the medical
benefits of it okay guess what multiple
studies say you know social distancing
works we have studies suggesting the
lockdown may have actually been bad we
have an economic crisis we have food
shortages food prices skyrocketing and
there's all of the reason to suggest we
should reopen YouTube just issued a
statement anybody who says anything
about the lock downs being bad is banned
boom outright Wow
so that video there's a video from a
doctor where he said we need I think he
said something like we need social
distancing but we can't do the lockdown
because we have to develop herd immunity
right YouTube deleted the video well he
didn't actually say herd immunity just
immunity in general yeah like when
you're locked inside you you lose your
natural immunity in general right the
point is if we have these cops in in New
Jersey violating the Constitution look
so let me show you the next Dory well
and we got we will get we do got a read
police charged woman with organizing a
protest at rogue analyst Jim that's some
context here what is this police charge
women for organizing a protest how does
that make sense they say according to a
statement from Belmar Police Chief
William Walsh they cited the gym owners
Frank trombetti me and Smith police have
also charged one person with obstructing
the administration of law while
reportedly because he refused to
identify himself to officers and police
charged anti shut down protester Ayla
Wolfe with organizing a protest I guess
that's it right here's a Murphy said I
don't begrudge anyone anyone's rights to
protest Murphy said in April this is
America we all have First Amendment
rights
I really wish they would do it at home
what all right you could protest don't
do it here go go do it at home I'm
really good protest I'm gonna protest
you right now who I don't know leave
we're gonna leave the camera running why
go in my room
and I'm gonna wave a sign up my window
I'm protesting neighbors look at me
listen this woman was arrested for quote
organizing a protest that's not a crime
nope it's not a crime but YouTube says
that if you do anything or say anything
that could encourage people to do
something dangerous they will ban you
they'll ban your video outright so when
he says you know go protest at home
wouldn't that like what options you have
other than to go on the internet and
protest and make people see it and you
can't answer so yet they're basically
making the First Amendment illegal how
so the other day I did a video about
people in Virginia flocking to the
beaches okay and people in New York are
out partying do this is this is crazy
stuff right no what's going on in New
York there's people jumping on cars and
just like taking the streets over and
they're twerking and they're doing
simulated sex stuff
no and it's just it's just bonkers in
New York City meanwhile the governor of
New Jersey is threatening a local gym
because they want to have some people
exercise what's worse they can't enforce
the other ones so they're gonna go after
this guy YouTube shadow band in my video
it didn't appear on my channel for most
people some people could see it I could
see it most people couldn't as a shadow
band right so I've been censored already
what happens when they come and they
just ban this channel outright my and my
other channels out right we can't talk
anymore they say no you're encouraging
you know dangerous things I mean
yesterday we were we were kind of on the
edge of talking about certain things I
don't even want to bring them up again
but you know for those who watched our
show yesterday we talked about it a
couple times like man this might give us
banned we're just gonna all be talking
about it yeah this might give us been
let's just keep talking about whatever
and trying to start our show today
YouTube was messing up it's still it
still is not updating I could see it
it's not normal it's not showing the
normal specs you know nothing's
different today than it was yesterday I
mean this happens we first tried
starting the show we were we weren't
seeing any concurrent numbers and he
likes any revenue and super chats
weren't low
and then now super Jets are loading but
nothing else is refreshing so we have I
have no idea when he likes there our
chat revenue it's supposed to show us
doesn't show us it's broken yeah I tried
walking up but anyway I think we're
dangerously close to something
nightmarish because you got alan
dershowitz saying the government can
force a needle into your arm yep yeah
I'm gonna say no to that's yeah he he he
also said you don't have a right to not
be vaccinated it's like what how is that
possible how can you decide whether or
not I get vaccinated or not there are
some things that make sense cuz I'm in
favor of vaccines right right I'm not in
favor of rush to treat like you know yes
whether like panicking precisely but for
if if a public school in my opinion says
you can't go here unless you're
vaccinated I'm cool dead I know where
that makes sense it's a public school if
the public you know ordinance is passed
saying these are the requirements we
have for what this school right home
school how much they don't like home
school right they don't like that yeah
that's the alternative it's like okay if
you don't want to vaccinate your kids
don't bring home to the school man yeah
done it's that easy so let's read and
see what Dershowitz said because I'm
telling you man we are dangerously close
I mean well I kind of feel like we're
over the precipice like we just right at
the edge yep and we're just falling at
this point yeah it feels like it here we
go a top lawyer who defended President
Trump during his Senate impeachment
trial believes the Constitution grants
the government power to vaccinate
citizens against their will speaking
with crowdsourced the truth host Jason
Goodman over the weekend Harvard
professor Alan Dershowitz at the public
safety outweighs any private liberty
concerns of US citizens who do not wish
to be vaccinated for the Caprona virus
what where does it say that in the
Constitution it sounds like he's just
making that up
those who what is it those who would
give up Essential Liberty for the
prospect of security deserve neither and
will lose both something like that I
don't know that's actually a quote from
no I don't I don't think it's a real
quote from a founding father I think it
was somebody said it and then they
attributed to him because otherwise is
what people like doing they've done it
for hundreds of years or longer they'll
say something they believe but attribute
it to a great person so that people will
listen yeah that is from Benjamin
Franklin are you are you sure yeah 100
NPR okay yeah I just lost context they
say okay yes why did you say that
specifically or
those
would give up Essential Liberty to
purchase a little temporary safety
deserve neither liberty nor safety there
you go yeah so so when when YouTube
comes a-knockin and they say you better
toe the line for the machine or else
I'll say or else yeah and we're here so
you know I say that we're dangerously
close because we're at a point where the
lard like the only that the monopolized
video platform right now is it's
basically saying we warned you bro
we shadow band your video if you keep
talking out about this yeah we'll just
knock you right out you must advocate
for the government to come and force you
to be medicated no this is the future
this is great no way so so you know I
like to think that there would be a
point you know when this all blows over
that there's gonna be like lawsuits yeah
there already are a lot of lawsuits I'm
not confident the governor of New Jersey
said we can't fully reopen until there's
a vaccine it's ridiculous I'm out I'm
out we're gonna we're gonna work we've
been looking for to expand finding a
building and we've been looking not
necessarily in in in in Jersey in other
states but we really wanted to do it
here because we were here and now it's
like nah we'll figure something else out
something something else out I'm not
gonna be in a state where you've got you
know legit des fêtes being like we are
you know here's the piece this is what
really freaks me out is that you have
this small business this gym and it's
like two guys and they're like we are
going to exercise and open our business
and he specifically tells them like he
like of everything he could be talking
about he goes after this one small
business these two guys who have no
power no authority and he's the governor
of this state and he's leveraging the
massive power that sit against this tiny
business meanwhile Walmart's profits are
up seventy four percent seventy four
percent yeah Wow big-box stores are
skyrocketing it's it's mad its 19 it's
it's not it's not like which dystopian
novel are we in again a little bit of
every single one you know you know so uh
for me I think the big concern with them
rushing the vaccine is I don't literally
think it's gonna be zombies or you know
mole people or whatever but I mean who
wants to be the guinea pig for the first
run of vaccines
some people do I don't
I don't definitely not so so so did you
guys answer the question all right no
you did you said no for the government
you know comment says drop trou turn
around but no anyway but uh so let's
check this out
he says quote let me put it very clearly
you have no constitutional rights to
endanger the public and spread disease
even if you disagree you have no right
not to be vaccinated you have no right
not to wear a mask you have no right to
open up your business Goodman
interjected to clarify whether
Dershowitz was saying the federal
government has the ability to mandate
vaccinations for all citizens absolutely
Dershowitz replied and if you refuse to
be vaccinated the state has the power to
literally take you to a doctor's office
and plunge a needle into your arm well
that's insane you know what I'd like to
see an taifa speak up
yeah we're there there's what's going on
they're agreeing with the government I
don't get all of them I think they're
hiding I think you know the problem for
a lot of these activists is that they
defended the establishment too much not
completely but too much okay when the
mainstream media was saying things like
you go into father and he fell rolled
with it and now that the establishment
saying okay now that you know you've
agreed with us we're gonna you know drag
you to an office and jam a needle in
your arm they're like just don't know it
don't say anything there's no actual you
know pushback or anything yeah that's
what democracy is about that's amazing
if the majority of the people agree and
support that for public health measures
you have to be vaccinated you have to be
vaccinated they should give you an
alternative the alternative is to live
in your home don't get vaccinated but
never leave your home or live in a
bubble but if you want to interact with
other people you cannot become typhoid
mary the constitution doesn't give you
the right to spread your illness to
other people Wow
ER Dershowitz argued that health care
workers and officials forcibly vatten in
the public through a legislative and
judicial process that comes to a
consensus on widespread vaccination is
the best defense against the spread of
the disease
so what company is making the vaccine
because I want to make some money I want
to invest in them because that seems
like what this is just a bunch of people
oh well we'll just you know make it a
law that you have to take this
that means the government has to buy it
from us so we'll make a million dollars
a billion dollars by Amazon stock what
Amazon owns oh no the vaccine or what a
government just shut down every small
business in the country yeah and so
people have no choice but to go to
Amazon and Walmart there you go that's a
if you got the cash you and you don't
need to worry you just bind to the big
box chains the big corporate stores and
you will see those stocks go up as all
the small businesses get crushed it's
gonna be great it's gonna be close don't
you understand Adam once this is all
over we'll have one store we'll have
Amazon everybody will be will be
injected by the government it's exactly
what the founding fathers were dreaming
of with their with their birth of a new
nation have you ever read the
Declaration of Independence you know we
are all created equally under God and we
we have the right to life liberty and to
be suffering under the mandate of
government against our will you know I'm
pretty sure that's what it said right
yeah yeah maybe maybe not verbatim but
interpretation which is what Alan
Dershowitz is doing basically yeah do
not want to hear that oh you know dick
ulis man I can't believe you said that I
think I'm gonna get banned I think I've
been waiting for it yeah because they've
been perfect I think what they're not
they're not doing bands they're doing
partner program purges so they're what
you just won't get paid for it yeah they
cut you off so you can't make money hmm
yep they want you to tow that line baby
well good thing we know uh someone who
just went over to Spotify with a pretty
good deal maybe we can you know I mean
you're friends with him or anything and
Jo spoken up a lot about you know about
the problems of the lockdowns and stuff
like that yes so I haven't followed
everything you said about the lockdown
but for those I'm sure everybody knows
by now Joe Rogan's leaving eventually is
main the main show's gonna be off you
tips and be on Spotify I hope I hope
that's a viable alternative but it's
gonna be probably like Hulu or Netflix
you've got to have you got to be in you
got it you got you gotta be in the club
you know that's what they want man so a
bunch of YouTube it has been very clever
about how they've purged everybody and
they've not banning people has gone too
far
and it sparks a huge backlash so now
they do you're removed from the partner
program but you can reapply later
oh so it lightens the devastation yeah
but they also don't do it all at once
they do like a little bit here and there
so they were there apparently some
channels that this is someone I know
told me this we're totally in the clear
mm-hmm news channels not conspiracy but
you know a little I don't the right word
is maybe not conspiratorial just not
well vetted okay you know purged gone so
I think YouTube is working its waste
it's working its way up this ladder I'm
like just eliminating content and
channels and you know okay because we
know where this is going
you know Donald Trump is talking about I
believe Trump was talking with this
deploying the military to deliver the
vaccine Wow when it's when it's
available and what's the mortality rate
right now based on the current numbers
we have it's like under one persona 0.12
or something like that point one to the
infection rate I think is around like
five percent now it's like way way lower
and none of this matters why we don't
know there's a lot of studies coming out
and I don't think there's a grand
conspiracy simply because a lot of you
know government funded and university
funded studies have come out showing
it's not that bad I think what we're
seeing is the new culture war is
specifically about this if Trump sport
were against it right you know so at
first the culture war was very much like
free speech hate speech and you had
these people who just opposed free
speech because and now it's it's you
know we need to reopen the economy
because people are gonna starve and
prices are going to skyrocket and I have
these other people have gone the other
direction they're like no no no we
should be locked down forever yeah so
then it's like they're they're
increasingly entertaining the extreme
then what's what's next yeah forced
vaccination I guess it feels like
they're really just trying to push on
the populace like let's see how far how
much authority we can gain here
seriously how does this end well but how
are they thinking that we can stay
lockdown forever and survive
I don't really know who's gonna do
anything about it any but look if
anybody on social media says hey we
should do something about it banned you
know instantly gone
so what happens people start defying the
government orders like this gym people
get arrested for
organizing protests and I think for the
most part no one will do anything
I really think no one will do anything I
think in certain parts of the country
people will just bunker down but I don't
think we'll see any kind of actual
resistance to this level of absurdity I
think certain states are gonna be like I
mean there's already states where their
police force is saying we're gonna
uphold the Constitution yeah and we're
not arresting anyone they're not doing
anything illegal so and other states are
like we're resting everyone no matter
what yep and it's gonna shift the
population around I think that's what's
gonna happen I think we're gonna become
the divided States of America yeah it's
gonna send I think a lot of people are
gonna I don't know I think this might
make tons of people conservative oh
definitely
cuz you got to think about the liberal
the liberals who went and bought guns
mm-hmm and the Liberals who are now can
you know I don't know the political
leaning of these gym owners hmm but this
this gym that's trying to reopen is in a
heavy blue district it's it's D plus 13
okay it's like we're just on the other
side of the river from Philadelphia so
it is very Democrat the the reps a
Democrat D plus 13 that means it never
goes red you know basically and then
just south of us is I believe it's NJ
too which is Jeff Andrews district was a
Democrats which were the Republican
Party oh right okay I I think the blue
states are going to be dramatically
weakened here's what I project right now
the governor came out and said we can't
you know we won't be back to normal the
new normal until there's a vaccine so he
mentioned like you know stores being
packed and people walking around
downtown you know that's that's normal
and I'm like you want me to sit in my
house for 18 months you know you know
it's scary is that most people have no
choice I'm privileged that's true I have
a business that relies on the internet
not on foot traffic right so these gym
owners they got what do they do
it's like close your gym down and get a
gym somewhere else not that easy you
know for me it's like we're we're
expanding and I'm looking to get a new
building I'll just get a building
somewhere else I mean even bigger
companies are closing Pier one closed
five 500 locations or something wow
that's crazy after like 50 years you
know so it's not even a small company
is the bigger companies and I'm sure
gyms are on that list yes exactly
the entire thing yeah it's huge so we're
gonna be is they're even gonna be gyms
opened like who what gym is owned by
Walmart
could you imagine their what no could
you imagine living in a city after this
no oh my goodness no dude this is nuts
New York is almost entirely small
business or almost in volumes
well not necessarily or like supremely
rich businesses like Starbucks or I mean
I can't think of anything you know Apple
an Apple store there's a Starbucks
there's a corner in in New York that I
could stand and do a spin and see
Starbucks there Starbucks there
Starbucks there yeah like five Starbucks
in one spot I could see them all but
that's that's that's just Starbucks New
York is almost entirely small businesses
okay individual bodegas sure sure
there's like very few massive
supermarkets there's Whole Foods there's
Trader Joe's and stuff mm-hmm but you
the bodegas are all that I believe the
bodega is a lot of them are like
franchise and networks kind of like
someone might own like four or five
bodegas yeah yeah I think White's our
it's a bunch of tiny restaurants you
walk down Manhattan like sixth Avenue
and it's like you know there's a tiny
Tyra Thai food restaurant the
cross-strait tiny Indian food restaurant
they merely have any seats they're all
like well it's mostly small business and
that I was I was reading or something
about this a long time ago I could be
wrong but I think New York City doesn't
allow Walmart okay I could be wrong
about that but Chicago is very straight
on Walmart's too because how it
devastates the small businesses yeah but
when you think about how the big chains
like Starbucks will be fun
because Starbucks still a lot of
Starbucks are still open and operating
across the country okay it's just in the
cities where they're shut down like some
and the places that have Drive thrus
yeah they're probably open just fine
that makes sense
so what's gonna happen after after 18
months or whatever New York finally
reopens people walk outside no stores
yeah no food just Starbucks if that man
because the local Starbucks is might
close that all the food spoiled you know
there's nothing left yeah they throw
everything away what do they do with it
but we are seeing a lot of places
lighten up the restrictions now so yeah
we may be coming out into the side of
this one yeah I mean that's what we said
we've been saying it's like calm and it
feels like it's lightening up - feels
like it's lightening up and then of
course they're arresting someone who are
like we're like or just a small gym or
just trying to open up it's like no no
no you broke the rules you're being
arrested for organizing a protest yeah
against this lockdown that we I mean it
seems like we don't need to be locked
down anymore why are we locked down
still well by saying that we'll get Ben
that's a question here that doesn't
matter that's how you do brawls baby I'm
just trying to put it on me well I'm
kidding I deny it
I don't know man I some people are
saying it's like it's a test to see how
far they can push people and I'm like
there's no conspiracy dude it's it's
it's this tribalism some people in that
time I've been saying it's fear dude you
know it is it's that everybody's
screaming at Trump mm-hmm Oh Trump
didn't lock down soon enough it's his
fault
yeah so these governors are like blamed
someone for it dude I if you were if the
average take take it take the average
person put them in the governor's seat
and they're gonna be like I don't want
to be responsible just lock it all down
forever until you impeach me I don't
care I won't be responsible for this
mm-hmm so when people protest
I'm sure if enough people protested the
governor would be like okay okay we're
gonna reopen but it's your fault if
anything happens that's exactly what
Whitmer was saying I'm doing this for
your own good you you need to be locked
down she's nuts I definitely agree with
you yeah she's like she's she's the
queen of Carens you know yeah actually
micro prisons could you see what
happened I saw us she was like I'm gonna
contact the manager of Twitter
I demand Trump be banned these people
are nuts
you know it's making everything worse oh
man can't you just like take a nice bath
you know no no I just mean you know get
some Epsom salt yeah relax well then
just light some candles
whoosah put on some Barry White just
chill out a lot of ideas here too
talking about some relaxing you've got a
really specific like yeah I mean it's
probably based off of like the 90s or
some cancel yeah
funny story and totally
relevant I had an apartment burned down
because somebody wanted to light candles
for this this chick that I knew and they
put a bunch of teddy bears around how
much candles like this is gonna be
romantic and then longer story than that
what I won't get into much dj''q because
it's irrelevant I just thought of it and
I was like yeah dude I'm uh I'm bored of
all this that's the other thing it's
like I wake up you know seeing these
stories and I'm like you know pissed off
no and I'm trying to do all these things
I'm kind of just like ready to go
gtfo you know West Virginia baby by uh
by the river
Shenandoah Shenandoah River get a little
shack yeah do I know the set will be the
exact same no one will have any idea in
a place that's younger than the
mountains new New Jersey has serious
problems with attracting Millennials
there because why would you want to live
here like you turn 20 years old you're
like i'ma go New York I'm gonna go to
Philly yeah I'm gonna go to LA it's a
good point wants to be in New Jersey
it's at the butt of every joke and so
it's true and also with attracting new
businesses and so now I'm like you know
what man I don't think the state cares
about my business or anyone else's I
think the leadership here one of the
biggest problems that I've seen with the
current generation of Democrats is that
if your whole political existence is
predicated upon saying whatever you need
to say just get elected but you don't
actually care about what happens next to
your community yeah that's true that's
how he came up with all these leaders
which ones who like what's-her-name
whitmer oh right and like the governor
of New Jersey I think it's even it's
even worse than that it's like there's
all these people empowered it feels like
they're reaching a point where they
don't care what happens to earth they're
like I'm gone in like 30 years anyway
why why do I care
yeah why do I care and that's it's an
attitude I see across almost all
everyone in the government right now
it's it's insane you're the worst thing
is is when I've debated communists
mm-hmm and they always go like not
always but a lot of won't be like dude
I'm fighting for a Star Trek kind of
future okay don't you want that and I'm
like you think communism will get us to
the point where we have spaceships and
like
post-scarcity they're nuts yeah but the
other problem is that I think I think
our governments too big
I think our populations are too big in
the sense that's how do you govern how
does one representative represent
750,000 people you're right they're all
100% different to you don't everybody's
different so you end up with like Ocasio
Cortes mm-hmm she doesn't actually care
about a district it's none of these
representatives do these people get
elected in their districts and then go
and complain about national level issues
you know not what their district is
concerned about exactly it's the
weirdest thing now they have to get
reelected but for the most part these
districts have all become D plus or R
plus mean that means no it's like in in
the reason Oh cause record has one is
because it's a Democrat guaranteed
district okay there was no election like
nobody shows up for the primary nobody
cared and because she rallied enough
activists and the Democrats just weren't
paying attention she won the primary and
then because the D plus 30 district well
people just walk in and go D they don't
think twice they don't care they don't
know someone tweeted at me actually that
she only got 14 signatures and she
needed 15 so she's not even on the
ballot or something no no I'm not I'm
not sure exactly what it was the Working
Families Party yeah okay so the Working
Families Party is kind of like an
activist ballot never really wins but it
always supports the Democrat mmm and
she's not gonna be on it but
interestingly she just had a debate with
her principal challenger Michelle Crisco
Cabrera caught her in a lie like a au
sein o AO c said that after this vote in
DC Michelle crystal Cabrera called her
out for like spending a week in her
luxury apartment in DC with like you
know complete with infinity pool and a
Whole Foods while her district was
suffering and dying from kovat and AOC
was like well I wasn't feeling well and
then crystal Cabrera I think she was one
who published to this showing the
timeline of AOC like doing Instagram
live with with Megan Rapinoe the soccer
player like you're doing celebrity live
streams and doing like she was there for
a week I guess you know posting these
videos like yeah just making tic TOCs
right exactly Megan Megan drinks
people in her kitchen yep in her luxury
apartment yeah and then what this is the
funniest thing crusoe Cabrera said you
lied and told people you were in the
Bronx and aoc said no I didn't because
apparently aoc said something like hey
to everyone here in the Bronx something
like that so she didn't actually say I'm
in the Bronx but she phrased it in a way
that people who were watching would
think she was back in New York when she
was really chilling in a luxury
apartment in DC gotta love it man I love
it I love it people have complained
about her but but you know I don't wanna
drag her specifically it's it's like too
many like Nancy Pelosi for sure it's
like come on dude your city is covered
in human waste the mummy lady woman I
don't think they any of these people
actually care the interesting thing is
it's like based on what these people
have done mm-hmm I really do think
they're like I think Rand Paul cares
deeply methods that principals like that
guys like my favorite politician I think
Dan Crenshaw cares
I think Tulsi cares and I think Trump
cares I think I think Trump cares about
America yeah but I think in my opinion
when it comes to the president he has
this view of like he has his view of
what America is and that's what he cares
about yeah that's a good point yeah so
where it's like I don't know how to
really kind of describe what I mean but
I think Trump has more of a personal
perspective on like this is America this
is what I care about and he's trying to
build America in this vision it's
literally what he says making America
great again yeah and so I look at
someone like Rand Paul it's relatively
similar the Constitution constitutional
rights you know but I think most these
people there there was a post on Reddit
that went viral where they were like
stop thinking that anyone cares about
you Trump doesn't care about you Bernie
doesn't care about you Biden doesn't
care about you they're crunching numbers
they're they're taught they're asking
their consultants what do they need to
say to convince people to vote and
they're targeting markets that's all it
is you know and I I you know what's
crazy as I hear that and I'm like I
don't know if I agree with that when it
comes to Trump because Trump is a
culture war icon and the people who are
voting for him I like especially on
social media
they're really invested in the culture
war and so they're like all about Trump
the memes the cause the movement and
then you look at the opposition and
there's no politician behind that you
know you know it's Trump or anti Trump
so I think it's fair to say Bernie
doesn't care about you I think it's fair
to say Biden doesn't care and you Biden
for the most I think Bernie cares a
little bit you know I don't think it's
fair to say that Trump doesn't because
Trump is a you know culture war you know
I think it's like he's here for his
mission then you look at Biden what's
Biden therefore so it helps a Clinton
Foundation get back into getting
hundreds millions of dollars in the
Saudis or something maybe yeah I think
he's a placeholder for who or what what
they gonna do I don't know who it's
gonna be but I can't I can't fathom him
actually debating trunk he's not gonna
do it he's not no I don't see it
happening I don't know what he's gonna
do
no I don't know what's gonna happen
everything is stupid everyone's dumb
everything is dumb thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you